mengukur superposisi Quantum adalah serawak membalikkan syiling tapi sampai mana kita boleh ambil analogi tu
sebelum ia rosak kita akan tahu hari ini dalam Qiskit di
bilik darjah selamat datang ke Qiskit di bilik darjah siri video di mana kita pecahkan konsep asas yang
mungkin korang jumpa dalam kursus berkaitan Quantum Computing setiap video disertai modul interaktif yang dipautkan dalam
deskripsi di bawah jadi pastikan korang tengok hari ini kita bercakap tentang salah satu prinsip teras di jantung
teori quantum superposisi dalam pengalaman harian kita objek sentiasa mempunyai ciri yang pasti lokasi saiz
bentuk warna segala-galanya tentang mereka adalah tetap dan pasti walaupun kita Pemerhati belum lagi mengukurnya dalam
dunia quantum ini tak semestinya kes objek Quantum boleh berada dalam apa yang dipanggil superposisi
beberapa keadaan klasikal yang dibenarkan yang apabila diukur akan runtuh secara rawak kepada salah satu daripada keadaan
tu mengukur keadaan superposisi adalah seperti membalikkan syiling tak ada cara untuk tahu terlebih dahulu ke arah mana ia akan
jatuh ketidakpastian asas ini adalah aspek mekanik quantum yang tidak selesa yang bahkan Einstein pernah susah
dengannya dia terkenal berkata Tuhan tidak main dadu tentang Keacakan ini tapi seperti yang kita akan lihat Tuhan sebenarnya memang main dadu atau dalam
kes kita dia membalikkan syiling tapi lebih dari itu syiling ini adalah tertumpu mengukur superposisi Quantum mungkin serupa dengan
membalikkan syiling dalam beberapa cara tapi superposisi itu sendiri jauh lebih kaya dan lebih kompleks daripada keadaan
kebarangkalian klasikal untuk melihat ini kita akan fikir tentang cara syiling klasikal berfungsi dan mengkontraskan ini dengan syiling
Quantum kita yang akan kita terokai menggunakan Qiskit pada komputer IBM quantum pertama syiling klasikal ia
agak mudah korang balikkan syiling dan ia jatuh sama ada kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah dengan 50% peluang masing-masing well pada prinsipnya kita boleh
kira syiling mana yang akan jatuh kalau kita tahu syarat awal tepat syiling dan tepat berapa
banyak daya dan tork yang diterapkan semasa balik tapi dalam amalan tak ada cara untuk tahu a priori ke arah mana syiling
akan jatuh itulah sebabnya kita guna balik syiling sebagai contoh kanonik keadaan kebarangkalian klasikal di mana
hasil pada dasarnya rawak kalau saya membalikkan syiling ini seribu kali dan merekod bilangan kepala ke atas
dan kepala ke bawah saya akan mendapat histogram yang kelihatan seperti ini jadi kita ada kiraan pada paksi Y
dan ia boleh sama ada kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah dan
histogram akan menunjukkan bahawa ada lebih kurang 500 kiraan setiap satu bergantung kepada beberapa
turun naik statistik kita boleh cipta keadaan yang serupa menggunakan qubit pada komputer quantum kita seperti balik syiling
qubit juga boleh diukur dalam dua kemungkinan keadaan sifar dan satu kalau kita gunakan sesuatu yang dipanggil Hadamard gate pada
Qubit ia akan meletakkannya dalam superposisi sama rata sifar dan satu ini adalah
visualisasi circuit tu yang kita panggil rajah circuit di sini wayar atas adalah
Qubit dan operasi yang diterapkan kepada Qubit muncul sebagai kotak pada wayar Hadamard gate ditunjukkan dengan kotak ini
berlabel H dan pengukuran ditunjukkan dengan kotak kelabu berlabel dengan simbol pengukuran kecil ia hantar pengukuran tu
ke bit klasikal wayar dengan dua garisan ini jadi memandangkan Qubit berada dalam superposisi sama rata 0 dan satu bila
kita ukur ia akan ada 50% peluang kita ukur sifar dan 50% kita ukur
satu kita nyatakan keadaan superposisi Quantum ini sebagai s = 1 / punca
2 0 + 1 / punca 2 1 di mana kuasa dua setiap pekali ini yang juga dipanggil amplitud adalah kebarangkalian mengukur setiap keadaan jadi dalam amalan menerapkan Hadamard
gate adalah analog kepada membalikkan syiling dan sama seperti kita membalikkan syiling seribu kali untuk tengok
statistik syiling jatuh kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah kita boleh buat sesuatu yang serupa pada Qiskit dengan syiling Quantum kita
kita akan guna primitive Qiskit yang dipanggil sampler yang akan ulang circuit beberapa kali untuk mensampel statistik
keadaan yang terhasil dengan seribu sampel circuit di atas kita ada sesuatu yang kelihatan pada dasarnya sama
dengan histogram syiling klasikal bergantung kepada beberapa turun naik statistik jadi adakah itu sahaja superposisi
quantum pada dasarnya sama dengan keadaan kebarangkalian klasikal serupa dengan membalikkan syiling tidak begitu ini akan
menjadi video yang agak pendek kalau itu kasusnya untuk melihat perbezaan utama pertama kita saya akan cuba sesuatu yang sedikit berbeza dengan syiling klasikal saya bukannya
hanya membiarkannya jatuh ke meja mendarat sama ada kepala ke atas atau ke bawah saya akan balikkan syiling dan tangkap ia
di udara antara tapak tangan saya sekarang syiling itu bukan kepala ke atas atau ke bawah tapi sebaliknya ia sama ada kepala ke kiri
atau ke kanan jadi logik memberitahu kita bahawa ini juga patut mempunyai kebarangkalian 50/50 sama ada
kepala ke kiri atau ke kanan untuk mengukur kepala ke kiri atau ke kanan pada syiling Quantum kita boleh buat apa yang kita buat dengan syiling klasikal
ukur sepanjang paksi berbeza pengukuran standard kita pada komputer quantum adalah sepanjang paksi menegak
sama seperti pengukuran kepala ke atas atau ke bawah biasa syiling klasikal tapi kita juga boleh tanya syiling Quantum kita sama ada ia
kepala ke kiri atau ke kanan kita panggil dua keadaan ini sepanjang paksi-x plus atau minus
untuk ini kita guna primitive Qiskit yang dipanggil estimator untuk merumitkan sedikit bukannya mengembalikan histogram seperti
sampler buat estimator sebaliknya akan memberi kita nilai jangkaan pemerhati qubit untuk
memahami nilai jangkaan ini katakan korang mendapat satu dolar setiap kali syiling mendarat kepala ke atas dan hilang satu dolar bila ia
mendarat kepala ke bawah nilai jangkaan adalah berapa banyak wang yang korang boleh jangkakan untuk diperolehi secara purata dengan setiap balik syiling memandangkan
korang sama kemungkinan mendapat atau kehilangan satu dolar nilai jangkaan akan menjadi sifar penaakulan yang sama boleh diterapkan
pada Qubit bila kita cari nilai jangkaan x apabila kita terapkan x kepada keadaan plus kita
mendapat nilai + satu dan kepada keadaan minus kita mendapat minus satu jadi kalau kita ada
taburan 50/50 kita akan mendapat nilai jangkaan sifar tapi kita tak dapat kita mendapat nilai jangkaan plus satu
bermaksud syiling selalu diukur menjadi plus sepanjang paksi-x itu seperti membalikkan syiling
menangkapnya dan menjamin bahawa kepala akan selalu menghadap ke kanan ini adalah kerana
superposisi bukan sekadar taburan kebarangkalian ingat cara kita menyatakan keadaan Quantum
s sama dengan C 0 dikali keadaan 0 tambah C1
dikali keadaan 1 di mana setiap pekali ini adalah kompleks bermaksud ia
WEBVTT
mempunyai bahagian nyata dan khayalan jadi ia memberitahu kita tentang kebarangkalian tapi ia juga menyembunyikan kuantiti lain yang dipanggil
fasa beberapa pekali C boleh ditulis seperti
ini di mana C sama dengan magnitud kali fasa ini di mana phi ini adalah
fasa ia agak seperti fasa gelombang atau lokasi puncak dan lembah gelombang kalau dua gelombang berada dalam fasa
dengan satu sama lain jadi puncak dan lembah mereka sejajar maka mereka akan bergabung membentuk gelombang dua kali ganda
tinggi kita panggil ini gangguan membina kalau mereka tidak dalam fasa seperti
ini maka mereka mengganggu secara pemusnah membatalkan sepenuhnya antara satu sama lain untuk melihat bagaimana fasa boleh menyebabkan
gangguan dalam syiling Quantum kita jom cuba menerapkan Hadamard dua kali bukannya sekali sahaja sekarang secara klasikal
ini tidak masuk akal kalau menerapkan Hadamard adalah setara dengan membalikkan syiling maka korang tidak boleh balikkan syiling yang sudah membalik tapi jom tengok apa
yang berlaku secara mekanikal quantum jadi kita terapkan Hadamard dua kali dan kita sampel keadaan yang terhasil
menakjubkan kita tidak lagi mempunyai kebarangkalian 50/50 histogram yang terhasil menunjukkan bahawa untuk setiap kes kita mengukur
Qubit berada dalam keadaan sifar jadi Hadamard kedua telah mengembalikan Qubit kepada keadaan sifar di mana kita mula ia
agak rumit untuk dilihat pada mulanya tapi ini adalah berkat gangguan keadaan quantum tapi bukannya
mengganggu dalam ruang sebenar seperti gelombang sebenar gangguan berlaku dalam ruang maklumat abstrak Qubit
Hadamard kedua menyebabkan bahagian sifar superposisi mengganggu secara membina manakala bahagian satu
superposisi mengganggu secara pemusnah dan hilang jom terokai lebih lanjut kita boleh tukar fasa menggunakan
sesuatu yang dipanggil phase gate jadi sekarang jom terapkan Hadamard untuk cipta superposisi terapkan anjakan fasa
Pi radian dan kemudian terapkan Hadamard kedua sekarang kelihatan seperti syiling Quantum kita selalu keluar berada dalam
keadaan satu anjakan fasa pi menukar bahagian-bahagian keadaan superposisi yang berada dalam fasa dan tidak dalam fasa antara satu sama lain
jadi keadaan akhir adalah satu bukannya sifar ini seperti membalikkan syiling dan semasa ia berada di udara mampu
untuk entah bagaimana menerapkan operasi yang akan menjamin ia selalu mendarat kepala ke atas atau selalu kepala ke bawah bergantung pada
operasi itu mustahil dalam kes klasikal tapi tidak dalam kes quantum apa yang kita pelajari daripada eksperimen ini adalah
bahawa keupayaan baru syiling quantum ini adalah akibat fasanya satu kualiti yang superposisi Quantum ada tapi taburan
kebarangkalian klasikal tidak jadi balik syiling biasa sebenarnya bukan analogi yang baik untuk
superposisi sebab ia tidak kata apa-apa tentang fasa ini saya rasa kita boleh buat lebih baik saya akan buat eksperimen lain
dengan syiling kita saya ada syiling duduk di atas meja kepala ke atas untuk menjadikannya kepala ke bawah saya hanya boleh baliknya ini adalah
setara pengiraan dengan gate NOT katakan kita nak bina operasi yang kalau diterapkan dua kali akan
setara dengan gate NOT ini kita boleh panggil operasi ini punca kuasa dua NOT jadi fikir tentang apa yang kita secara fizikalnya buat
apabila kita menerapkan gate NOT kita memutarnya 180° sekitar contohnya paksi-x jadi kalau kita hendak putar syiling
hanya 90° sekitar paksi-x itu akan memberi kita punca kuasa dua NOT jadi kita telah menerapkan
punca kuasa dua NOT kita dan syiling hanya duduk di tepinya sekarang kita boleh tanya sama ada ia kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah well
jelas ia bukan mana-mana tapi kita boleh tambahkan langkah kepada proses pengukuran untuk memaksanya menjadi kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah sekarang
syiling akan jatuh ke sama ada kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah dengan kebarangkalian yang sama sekali lagi pada prinsipnya kita boleh ramalkan
ke mana ia akan jatuh tapi dalam amalan ini cukup susah untuk diramalkan sehingga membuatnya pada dasarnya rawak kalau saya nak
ukur sama ada kepala ke kiri atau ke kanan saya boleh renyuk dalam arah itu dengan cara yang serupa dan ia juga akan memberi kita
kebarangkalian 50/50 kiri dan kanan tapi dalam dimensi ini kepala depan atau belakang
kepala sudah menghadap ke hadapan jadi 100% masa kita akan mengukurnya kepala ke hadapan jadi sementara pengukuran x dan z
menghasilkan keputusan rawak pengukuran Y akan sentiasa menghasilkan hasil yang sama kalau kita fikir balik kepada
eksperimen balik syiling quantum dari bahagian sebelumnya ini mengingatkan cara syiling quantum berkelakuan selepas
menerapkan Hadamard Qubit diukur menjadi sama ada sifar atau 1 dengan kebarangkalian 50/50 dalam Arah Z tapi
selalu keadaan plus dan tidak pernah keadaan minus sepanjang X ini mencadangkan mungkin syiling berdiri diam di tepinya
adalah cara yang lebih baik untuk menggambarkan keadaan superposisi qubit daripada syiling yang membalik liar di udara
jom terapkan gate punca kuasa dua NOT pada syiling Quantum kita dalam Qiskit kita ada circuit mudah
ini kemudian kita akan guna estimator untuk semak nilai jangkaan tiga pemerhati X Y dan Z yang lebih kurang
seperti meruntuhkan syiling kita sepanjang setiap tiga dimensi seperti yang saya tunjukkan baru-baru ini jadi nilai jangkaan adalah 0
minus satu dan 0 untuk X Y dan Z masing-masing ini adalah keputusan yang sama yang kita
dapat untuk putaran punca kuasa dua NOT yang diterapkan pada syiling klasikal sebenarnya ada analogi yang tepat antara
syiling dan keadaan Qubit sekarang kita boleh menggambarkan keadaan Qubit sebagai vektor yang menghala dalam arah kepala
pada syiling normal kepada permukaan syiling jadi kepala ke atas atau keadaan sifar
pada syiling quantum adalah setara dengan vektor yang menghala lurus ke atas kepala ke bawah atau satu adalah menghala lurus ke bawah dan mana-mana
superposisi sama rata 0 dan satu menghala mendatar fasa keadaan quantum menentukan tepat
Arah mendatar yang ia hala contohnya sama ada ia menghala sepanjang paksi-x atau sepanjang paksi-Y atau di suatu tempat
di antara vektor ini dikenali sebagai vektor Bloch dan ia menentukan sepenuhnya dan secara unik keadaan quantum qubit tunggal
kita sekarang boleh bayangkan semula setiap gate yang kita lihat dalam video ini sebagai putaran atau siri putaran pada
syiling atau secara setara pada Vektor Bloch gate NOT adalah putaran
180° sekitar paksi-x apabila diterapkan kepada keadaan sifar kita atau kepala ke atas ia membalik ke
keadaan bawah atau satu punca kuasa dua NOT hanyalah 90° sekitar paksi-x yang sama bermula
dari keadaan kepala ke atas ini memutarnya ke kepala ke hadapan phase gate adalah putaran fi sekitar paksi-Z memandangkan
kepala ke atas adalah sejajar dengan paksi-Z ini tidak buat apa-apa kepada syiling Hadamard gate agak lebih rumit kita
pada mulanya menyamakannya dengan membalikkan syiling menjadikan syiling berputar tidak terkawal di udara tapi Hadamard sebenarnya adalah
WEBVTT
putaran deterministik terkawal pada syiling seperti semua gate lain Hadamard dilakukan dengan memutar 90°
sekitar paksi-Y kemudian 180° sekitar paksi-X jadi bila diterapkan pada keadaan kepala ke atas ia
berakhir menjadi kepala ke kanan jadi tak ada apa yang rawak tentang keadaan superposisi Quantum atau mana-mana
operasi standard yang kita lakukan pada Qubit setiap operasi adalah deterministik dan boleh berbalik satu-satunya
masa kerawakan terlibat adalah bila kita memutuskan untuk mengukur keadaan quantum sama ada keadaan Quantum berada dalam
superposisi atau tidak sebenarnya bergantung pada pandangan pemerhatia macam yang korang dah mungkin temui kita bebas memilih
sistem koordinat kita X Y dan Z boleh menghala sepanjang mana-mana tiga arah berserenjang jadi
kalau kita ada superposisi 0 dan satu dalam satu sistem koordinat kita boleh takrifkan sistem koordinat baru atau apa yang dipanggil
asas baru di mana keadaan menghala tepat dalam arah plus Z dan oleh itu bukan dalam keadaan superposisi
jadi bila kita kata sebuah Qubit berada dalam superposisi kita mesti juga takrifkan sistem koordinat kita atau
asas kita korang mungkin meninggalkan modul ini dengan gambaran bahawa kita baru sahaja menghapuskan semua misteri daripada mekanik quantum
lagipun salah satu aspek yang kononnya paling pelik iaitu keadaan superposisi sebuah Qubit sebenarnya semudah sebuah
vektor tiga dimensi tapi ingat bahawa syiling masih hanya analogi dan bahkan vektor Bloch pun hanya
alat visualisasi untuk mengira kebarangkalian hasil pengukuran kita tak boleh kata apa yang sebenarnya dilakukan oleh keadaan Quantum
sebelum ia diukur kerana menyemak itu memerlukan pengukuran kita akan bincangkan
teka-teki tentang apa sifat sebenar Keadaan Quantum dan bagaimana fenomena quantum belitan boleh membantu kita
menjelaskan ini dalam episod lain Qiskit di bilik darjah yang membahas ketaksamaan Bell sementara itu kalau korang
nak main dengan syiling Quantum untuk belajar sendiri tentang keadaan superposisi Qubit dan cara mengawalnya
pergi ke modul syiling quantum yang dipautkan dalam deskripsi terima kasih kerana menonton dan jumpa korang kali berikutnya